do you think one day technology will
allow individual human beings to become
immortal besides just through the
ability to digitize our essence yeah I
think that artificial intelligence will
give us the key to to genetic
immortality you see in the coming
decades everyone's going to have their
gene sequence we'll have billions of
genomes of old people
billions of genomes of young people and
what are we going to do with it we're
gonna run into an AI machine which has a
pattern recognition to look for the Aged
genes in other words the Fountain of
Youth that Emperor's kings and queens
lusted a ver over the Fountain of Youth
will be found by artificial intelligence
artificial intelligence will identify
where these aged genes are located first
of all what is aging we now know what
aging is aging is the build up of errors
that's all aging is the build up of
genetic errors this means that cells
eventually become slower sluggish
if they go into senescence and they die
in fact that's why we die we die because
of the build up of mistakes in our
genome in our cellular activity but
you've seen the future we'll be able to
fix those genes with CRISPR type
technologies and perhaps even live
forever so let me ask you a question
we're just aging take place in a car
given a car
where does aging take place well it's
obvious the engine right a that's where
you have a lot of moving parts B that's
where you have combustion well where in
the cell do we have combustion the
mitochondria we know know where ageing
takes place and if we cure many of the
mistakes that build up in the
mitochondria of the cell we could become
immortal let me ask you if you yourself
could become immortal would you damn
straight
now I think about it for a while because
of course if the term it depends on how
you become immortal you know there's a
famous
myth of Tiffany's it turns out that
years ago the in the Greeks mythology
there was the saga of Tiffany's and
Aurora Aurora was the goddess of the
dawn and she fell in love with a mortal
a human called
Athena's and so Aurora begged big Zeus
to grant her the the gift of immortality
to give to her lover so Zeus took pity
on Aurora and made Tiffany's immortal
but you see Aurora made a mistake a huge
mistake
she asked for immortality but she forgot
to ask for eternal youth
so port Athena's got older and older and
older every year decrepit a bag of bones
but he could never die never done
quality of life is important so I think
immortality is a great idea as long as
you also have a mortal youth as well now
I personally believe and I cannot prove
this I personally believe that our
grandkids may have the option of
reaching the age of 30 and then stopping
they may like being age 30 is you have
wisdom do you have all the benefits of
age and maturity and you still live
forever with a healthy body our
descendants may like being 30 for
several centuries
you